قد تبدو جزر بولينيزيا الفرنسية الشاعرية
وكأنها جنة للاسترخاء من
الشعاب المرجانية البكر والمياه الصافية ، ولكن يمكنك
الغطس تحت السطح ، هل أنت مستعد
للسباحة
[موسيقى]
ساخاروفا عبارة عن شكل مستطيل الشكل يقع
في بولينيزيا الفرنسية في جنوب المحيط
الهادئ  يُعرف الممر الجنوبي لأقصى
كاورافا باسم جدار القرش الرمادي نظرًا
لوجود أعلى تركيز
لأسماك قرش الشعاب المرجانية الرمادية في العالم منذ عام 2006 ،
تمت حماية أسماك القرش من الصيد
والتي تُعزى إلى
الزيادة السكانية خلال اليوم الذي تكون فيه أسماك القرش
زعيمة عادلة  الأسلوب والحفاظ على الطاقة على
استعداد لاصطياد فرائسها في الليل
على الرغم من أن العدد الدقيق لأسماك القرش
الموجودة في أسماك القرش غير مؤكد نظرًا لوجود
650 شخصًا فقط من البشر ، فمن المحتمل أن
يكون عدد الأشخاص يفوقك عددًا
[موسيقى]